[Music]
on a sunny morning at Disney's Animal
Kingdom theme park
the meerkats come outside to catch some
rays they like to lay in the sun some
people call them solar powered so they
sit like this with their little bellies
up to the sky
you'll see I'm kind of sitting in the
sun taking it in especially early in the
morning on those cooler mornings or if
it's been kind of rainy
foreign
[Music]
not to pick favorites I love all the
meerkats very much and they all are very
special
hi buddy you are so cute I know I love
you
I can't favor you on camera that's just
embarrassing
Southern African desert dudes love their
creepy crawly snacks
so today I'm feeding the meerkats
superworms and mealworms and they
definitely love those super worms it's
their favorite snack
I've been working with them for a really
long time that means that I've been able
to learn all their individual quirks and
personalities and so I can sort of tell
them apart by what they're doing
Thomas Arlo Springsteen Bentley Nirvana
Newton
[Music]
at this moment in time I would say that
Newton is probably our dominant animal
which is surprising to me because he's
one of our youngest animals
being the dominant male matters in the
meerkat mob your job is kind of
determined in some ways by your social
ranking within the group so in a typical
group there would be a dominant female
who selects a dominant male and they
breed and then the other members of the
mob are responsible for raising The
Offspring finding food taking Century
Duty which means look out to keep
everybody safe all of that kind of stuff
falls on the other members of the group
Bentley's in the back there scanning the
sky and the surrounding area to make
sure there are no threats that are
eminent that everybody needs to be aware
of
Bentley is a really fun guy he is very
chill I would say he's really calm and
easy going for the most part
[Music]
oh so that was an alarm call
looks like he might have seen something
in this guy that I cannot see
they have a specific vocalization for
Sky Predator versus land predator
something happened we're all seeking
shelter
oh we're scared of the zebra
those are our neighbors you all know the
zebra
okay we're all
we're all
when the coast is clear lower ranking
Bentley comes out with some attitude
Bentley is definitely not in charge and
when it comes to our meerkat social
rankings but sometimes he likes to try
it out and see how high he can get and
test the waters
There's Something Brewing potentially
[Music]
thank you